okay the time being 11 o'clock in the
morning I want to call the committee of
conference on hb2 together good morning
and I'm representative Len El will be
chairing this committee getting a budget
together takes a village and we have a
village here helping us so I want to
start with the house committee members
representative Ken Wier who chairs house
finance speaker Sheron
Packard um the lovely Karen umberger
seems to be not at the table but we'll
be back shortly she's working on
something representative ly
turot as alternates we have
representative Jess Edwards
representative Peter leichman who's also
not here yet representative Mary Jane
walner representative Norm major who is
chair of house Ways and Means
representative Tracy Emerich and
representative keither I would be remiss
to forget to mention that we always have
LBA and the staff here who do everything
for us Mr Michael Kaine Mr Chris Shay Mr
Michael Hoffman who held my hand
throughout the hb1 and hb2 division one
deliberations
represent I'm sorry Mr Mickey landrian
who worked with Karen umberger on
division two and finally but not
least Mr Kevin Ripple who worked with
Jess Edwards on division
three Senate President Morris would you
like to introduce your people sure I
thought we were voting on hp2 the way
you were going yeah well no
such I'm joined by Senator Rosenwald and
Senator Bradley um and Senator Daniels
even though the Senate really doesn't
have alternates is here um in case he's
needed no offense Senator Rosen but the
um we're uh looking forward to getting
going so Senator Morris typically the
committee of conference proceeds by
saying sections we've agreed on in hp2
we pass through as agreement we do have
a couple of SE sections I know we've
talked about HB
14 sections 14 and 15 but we didn't
agree on 15 that you amended it so I'd
like to move those forward and then I
would like to go through as we normally
do if either side has an issue with a
section we will just say hold put it on
hold if we have something to discuss we
can discuss it is that acceptable with
the Senate yes
okay we are going to start with our side
by side which is a mere 300 plus pages
so we're going to just zip right through
that in
about 15
hours we have actually House and Senate
agreed on every section down to section
14 which was the same I will tell you
that when division one me meets with
their
groups we
send a letter to all of them and we say
we're going to go through your budget we
want to know if you have issues with
anything in hb2 we want to know if
something needs to be added to hb2 you
should be prepared to answer these
budget questions as well as any other
question New Hampshire retirement system
came to us with those same Provisions
they had no issues with section 14 and
we passed those on to the Senate because
they were approved the Senate worked on
them and I believe there started to be
an issue from the retirement
system about Senate bill hb2 14 and 15
when it was in the Senate they sent me a
letter in June four months after we had
met with them saying Oh we have an issue
here so we've looked at it fairly ex
extensively worked with the groups and
Senate President Morris I would like to
have
LBA pass
out
Amendment 1937 H which deals with this
and Mr Kane when everybody has it can
you please go over the
amendment
thank you
sir
I think we're ready Mr King okay sure um
Amendment
1937 H is an amendment to house bill to
from representative obber um what this
so sections 14 and 15 is representative
overstated uh has to do with the
retirement system uh the medical
benefits and uh how the various members
actually pay uh for their portions uh
there is a um a current discussion going
on between between Das and retirement
system um as a result there was section
14 and 15 were put into house bill two
uh but there was a concern as
representative over stated relative to a
potential impact on the tax qualified
status of the retirement plan uh
retirement system did send a letter
which they did recommend um if these
sections were in that there should be a
uh tax determination letter from the IRS
um should be sought by the Retirement
Systems and so what this section will do
is its contingent implementation so no
change to section 1415 but basically
those sections will take effect uh 90
days after the receipt of a favorable
determination letter is presented to uh
the fiscal Committee of the general
court um and this is just to ensure that
the state does not impact the tax
favorable status of the retirement
system questions from the committee
members
I'll move the item second thank you
Senator Morris moves that we adopt
Amendment 202 one-1
1937 represent Wilder seconds house
members if you're in favor would you
please raise your
hands Senator Morris senate
members the motion passes unanimously
and with that we will also move sections
14 and 15 in
hb2 over thank
you that brings us to section 16 on page
12 the house would like to hold section
16 and
16a the next page that we have a change
on we go to page
section
20 the house exceeds to the Senate
language section
21 I am sorry section 19 is amended by
the Senate we would like to
hold you guys are going to get tired
seeing us flip our page just back and
forth we're on page
14 the next section and we are looking
at hb2 is passed by the Senate when I
call the section
numbers section
23 we would like to
hold section 24 the house exceeds to the
Senate
that brings us to page
20 section
36 the house would like to
hold
section 37
39 we go up
to
40 the house exceeds to the
Senate brings us to page
27 Mr Kaine could LBA pass out Amendment
19318 to all the members please
yes
for
I have
one this is a combination of what the
house passed and what the Senate
passed it basically puts together mental
health
support under the National Guard we're
appropriating $1.5
million it also ask the National Guard
to coordinate with veterans mental
health services offered in the VA the VA
does a variety of groups pts group Etc
and there is an A bill Federal Bill
going through now that would set up a
green alert when a veteran goes missing
and we would coordinate with that are
there any questions from members of the
committee
Senator Bradley moves Amendment 2021 d19
31h representative wer
seconds house if you're in favor please
raise your
hands
Senate
fav okay unanimous that passes
unanimously and we have moved section 43
forward
the house exceeds to Senate section
45 which goes through ads privacy
protection and it goes through several
pages
I don't know how many pages does it go
through Mr
Kane goes all the way to page uh 39 I
believe the um okay we haveed to that
thank
you the
next section we had a difference was
section 51 house senate section
51 the house exceeds to the Senate on
that language which is average me
membership and attendance representative
umberger and her team said that was a
good
idea we move to page
41 the Senate added and relief and
changed the RSA reference the house
exceeds to that language on page 41
moving us to
page 4
42 we have sections Senate sections 53
54 55 and 56 all relating to the same
thing as well as I
think 57 and
58 ending with Section
59 and the house exceeds to the Senate
language section 60 on page
44 has a change on
page
47 Mr Kane could you talk about this
change sure so this change on page uh 45
adds to the education trust fund
allowances um to allow them to fund the
Department of Education operating cost
for student data collection and
Reporting System which is consistent
with an appropriation provided in
section
59 um for that the senate had provided
um from the education trust fund because
they are using the education trust fund
that statute did have to be changed by
the yellow uh you can see on page
45 thank you the house succeeds to that
the next change
is
page
52 that affects the wastewater treatment
grants the house was delighted to see
this and we exceed to
this we're now going to go to section 58
I'm sorry page
58 section
85 which is the frm victims contribution
Recovery Fund the house and the Senate
are in agreement on this fund and on the
amount of money the language and the
funding of the section changed slightly
from what the house
had I'm not my green dress today but I
am always jealous that you guys have
more money we have we acceed to your
plan and we are now flipping Pages where
we are in in total agreement between the
two
bills
on page
71 section
112 while the house was in total
agreement with the Senate we had s
sp3 which passed and was signed into
law so we no longer need this
in this section and Mr
Cain there is an amendment to delete
this section because this is already law
and I've have already lost a piece of
paper so I don't know the number can we
just pass it out yes we will pass that
out thank you so
much
so the amendment number that's being
handed out is
1900h which as representative over
stated deletes the PPP section since a
bill has been signed into
law so
move Senator Morse moves speaker Packard
seconds the house if you're in favor
please raise your
hands this if you're in favor
our vote is unanimous we were delighted
to have that moved into law
earlier Mr Kane we're on page
72 and we have Senate Amendment 113 the
meals and rooms tax and this is revenue
sharing and I believe under what the
Senate was able to do we're going to be
sending more money to the towns is that
true and could you tell us a little bit
about that
correct so senate pass sections
113 as well as references contained in
114 and
115 uh what that does is it carves out
30% of all meals and rooms Revenue
collections into a new dedicated fund
for municipal
distribution uh that ended up increasing
it will increase the distributions to
cities and towns by about 35 million
over the bium uh this will be a non
budgeted restricted account um so you
will see that carved out of the general
fund revenues prior to the um beginning
of the fiscal year so this actually
provides a way for towns to have a more
reliable stream if you will of Revenue
sharing that will be coming to them
instead of worrying year year by year is
that true
correct Senator rosenal thank you I'm
not opposed to this but it does reduce
the percentage of rooms and meals tax
that goes to the cities and towns I know
we haven't hit that in a while but um I
think we should recognize that dedicated
funds get
suspended frequently by the
legislature and um so I want to note
that I have a concern about the
sustainability going forward because of
all of the tax cuts that are contained
within House Bill too Senator Madam
chair yeah I just want to make it clear
what happened here we're sending 188
million back to our communities which is
an additional $50 million that's
included in this budget um so I I
support it 100% And I would hope future
legislator fight to get to 40% to be
honest with you but um 30% was with we
believed we could talk to the house and
the municipal
Association um to do some good in this
budget and we
did the house is happy to acceed to the
Senate
recommendation I'd like to turn to page
75 at this
point this is a new section with a
commission to study and limiting the
business tax carryover um representative
major would you like to speak to this m
Kane why don't you tell us what it does
while we switch people
around sure so on page 76 of the side by
side um it is section
118 of the senate pass version and this
is the commission to study limiting the
business tax credit carryover uh
business tax credit carryover is sums in
the amount of $300 million plus or minus
uh every year that businesses carry
forward on what they pay um through
their business profits tax so um what
this commission would do is to study uh
the use of that credit u there's also a
section prior to that that does phase
down that credit over several years what
the Senate added on page 76 in yellow is
that the commission shall also examine
whether a business tax credit or other
type of credit could be made available
to those entities using their credit
carryover refund to invest in affordable
housing development so it's an
additional um resp responsibility of the
commission thank you represent major
would you like to
comment
yes is that on if you hold the button
down
okay yes credit carryover has been
climbing each year just a few years ago
was like
A40
million now as said is approaching $300
million that is a great a good
percentage of our business profits
tax and all of a sudden if things got
worse for the corporations they could
ask for that money back and all of a
sudden we have a big hole in our budget
because we go on a on a cash basis and
this is figured into our cash
basis so it's money that we really
shouldn't have but been held by us one
good thing for the uh corporations if
they have excess funds they they they
can park it in the state and not have to
worry about bringing it back and paying
their corporate taxes on
that well this is good good Amendment
Senator
moris the Senate just plain ran out of
time and I know it'll be a debate later
why the Senate put 25 million
additionally into affordable housing
fund but but the intention was that as
time moves on that we encourage
businesses and this is probably 50 of
the largest businesses in New Hampshire
to start to build on their own um we
looked into Dartmouth they're building
like 300 units over there for their own
employees um somehow if we could have
come up with a plan to put this 25
million um into play and have businesses
use the money they've already sank into
the government and take it out and do
developments to help with their own
planning um I think it would be
beneficial to the state of New Hampshire
um and that's where we're headed it's
going to take a little while longer I
would think in January we' come back and
address
this represent major do you have a
question my question is just an
observation is that I wasn't aware of
this this part of the
amendment
go ahead there is no part we basically
think the legisl needs to come back and
debate this because the reality is you
accounted for 20 million coming out of
that Fund in your budget um because they
were at 280 I believe is that the number
that's in there um and the house
accounted for that we thought that was a
great idea but what we'd like to suggest
if these businesses are going to start
taking money out of there they could
take that and this is going to be future
legislation we're not there yet and
apply for housing credits which there
are no dollars to do that I mean so we
thought that that might be a solution
the legislature could come back in
January and work on so that the 280
would start to come down in a manner
that is good for the State of New
Hampshire we're not there yet but that's
why we did it that way and that's why we
took 2021 monies and put it away um if
it gets spent before then obviously uh
we won't have that
opportunity so this puts together as I
understand this a study committee to
start looking at that and maybe making
some recommendations for future
legislation is that true Senator
Morris
yes
okay the house exceeds to that section
thank you on page 77 we do have a
question we had house section
111 which dealt with New Hampshire veter
Home per DM
payments Mr Kane did that get put into
the budget as a footnote or handled in
some other way yes that's included in
house bill one as a footnote on the
Veterans Home accounts so they can they
don't have to adjust their payments or
their Appropriations based on per deem
payment levels so was a duplicate
section that was
removed
okay
okay um we're going to turn now to page
78 we have some questions on 112 and 13
again these are New Hampshire Veterans
Home waivers Mr Kane what can you tell
us about those yes uh same discussion
relative to these um there were two
sections duplicate sections changes to
rsas that were not necessary uh Veterans
Home has given broader transfer
Authority than other agencies and are
exempt from certain rsas um they have
one section that does allow them to do
this and I believe that is
section uh 122 and so there was no need
Senate section 122 so there no need for
the other sections the Senate deleted
so Senate section
122 takes care of these two sections and
these could be deleted but they would
still have the same right correct that's
correct representative Edwards we're
okay
yes all right moving quickly
Along on page
80 the Senate did not use house section
117 I've had a question a a request to
hold that and and have a discussion
later and so we're going to mark that as
held that brings us to page
84 section 127 The Adult Parole Board
there were minor changes made here and
the house is exceeding to those changes
es and now we're going to flip pages
again there are some things that the
house had put in that were taken out our
section 126 which was about the workers
comp appeals board and our section 128
which was about um a new program that we
thought should be in there for
apprenticeships have been passed into
law and therefore are no longer needed
NH
hb2 we are zipping right
[Music]
along
changing going up to page
95 representative
umberger I think you wanted to hold this
section is that true would you like to
speak uh yes uh
that they are happy with what the and so
I would like to acceed okay the house
will exceed to section 135 thank you
representative
umberger we are on page 100
Senate
section
150 this is a quorum change a very small
change and it specifies who will
appoint the house succeeds to
that and now you watch this flip pages
where we were in total agreement
agreement
again the Senate did a wonderful job
agreeing with the house we thank
you
100% okay we are going to move to
section page 124 it says amended by the
Senate but you actually have
to turn the
page and this
is start start S for those of you
watching What appears to be page after
page of the newly created Department of
energy what has been proposed and both
the house and the Senate have agreed to
with minor changes is a department of
energy that is comprised of the
Pu office of strategic initiatives minus
a few
people the site evaluation committee two
members of The OSI moved to das the
planners that were in the office of
strategic initiatives moved to
Bea this made I can't tell you how many
changes in the rsas to existing statutes
so we're going to go through a lot of
sections we had a question the house had
started I'm sorry uh but I thought the
house uh had wanted to hold
um 154 through
156 what page
Karen sorry page
103 hang
on how section 154 156 representative
over on page 103 excuse me section
correct there is no change you are
correct there is a a question and Karen
umberger because there is a program that
she started that you guys agreed
to is getting a small amendment is that
correct representative V Berger yes so
while there is no change there was also
a section in division two that division
this came to division one that division
one was unaware of starting a program in
the police training and standards as
representative umberger said this
morning so she is going to get a little
Amendment and Mr Caine if you could hold
that which is one section 158 on
103 and then turning to page
104 through 160 correct through
yes thank you representative amberger uh
thank you and I'm sorry Senator BR we
only had 300 pages to go
through I should have written that in
red I had it in black and it just zipped
by all right we we would like on page
125 there's one small change in
paragraph three the the house had
administrative Technical and staff
support and we certainly see that staff
is redundant to
administrative however we were concerned
about the removal of technical support
and we wondered what the thought process
was with the
Senate I don't either I would move we a
seed to the house position
I'll second that representative Senator
Bradley moves that we exceed to the
house position by adding technical back
in and I have seconded that is there any
discussion
representative Jess Edwards you had the
question you're okay with that Senator
rosenal did you have a question okay is
the house on the am amendment to add
technical back in is the house in
agreement please raise your hand and the
senate senate
agreement unanimous we are
unanimous and
now we have section after section that
makes changes to
rsas on page
128 and
the Deputy word Deputy Commissioner was
added in on
127 on
128 while you remove technical you said
all necessary support so we are going to
exceed to both of
those and we're now going to turn to
page
129 we exceed to the Senate language at
the top of page
129 we were the same on page 130 and
131 we would ask the senate or LBA for a
little help Mr Kane this is on page
132 yes they added no change to house
language p rsaa 12- p col 10 and they
added a c reference but they left out I
believe what we had for 11 so can you
explain to me and to us what was going
on here I'm gonna ask Mike Hoffman if he
can verify if not I believe this was
part of a larger governor's office
Amendment provided to the Senate but um
I'll see if Mike can help
out yes excuse me good morning um that
note is just there to indicate the two
side by sides didn't line up very well
so several Pages down you'll see the
Senate has a section 12 p15 that is the
same language it just doesn't align up
with these Pages the way the bills lay
out and and that is on page
134 yeah and Mike on page
133 it looks like
the language we had for 12- p col 11 on
the CDE is 12- p col1 is that
correct
yes and we have a reference change on
page 134 as well
which is a
cleanup represented over representative
umberger um I thought we were going to
ask about taking out
um 12p 13 authority to contract for
power well we're trying to work through
that so okay I Mr Hoffman could you hear
do you have the mic on Ken yes I do
could you hear representative umberger
she was asking about 12
p113 which we believe was in the house
section and came from the
governor and Now does not appear to be
there and how many amendments did you
make on this at least
35 at
least 12 p133 on at the bottom of page
133 on the house
side
and yes you're correct that I was
confusing it with the other section
that's
duplicated did that language go the
Senate with it removed from the
governor's office
you think it's okay to put back
Jud um Mr Elms is here from the
governor's office we wish the governor's
budget director the very best he
actually got married on Saturday so
Chris Elms is here to help us Chris can
you Enlighten
this
okay so it was
removed I know you can't hear him if
you're at home doesn't have a microphone
it was removed because that has been
eliminated with restructuring but
somehow stayed on the
books all
right the house succeeds to all
those at the top at the top of page
136 the house had language from the
governor's office that
originally repealed the
OSI revolving funds however as this went
through the
Senate it was discovered that they
needed it they not only needed it they
had to make some RSA changes so the
house is exceeding to the Senate
language one section 190 revolves around
that
191 and we exceed to those as well the
next section we were the same on
now we turn to
page 137 in
Mike I can't tell you how many times
this weekend I read this section yes so
let me start with in line
two it says shall be appointed by the
commissioner I thought directors but I
didn't hunt up the law and the rsas were
nominated by Commissioners and actually
appointed through the
GNC uh some are uh but there are some
that are uh appointed directly by the
commissioner so these ones would not
require uh GNC
approval okay now my next
question it says the following positions
are hereby established y y and shall be
appointed by the commissioner and
perform assigned duties applicable to
law and then it lists the director of
regular regulatory Support Enforcement
policy and programs director of
administration Deputy of the
commissioner of energy and then it
appears that the commissioner is
appointing himself Commissioner of
energy correct that's how that reads
so should we perhaps change that would
you like a motion Madam chair yes we
that we delete that line I think it's 9u
9968 I would second that motion that
would delete the commissioner appointing
himself the house is in favor raise your
hands the
Senate and we we will move section
on
happle okay okay
um what happened here is basically
Senate section 19 194 move much of house
SE section 187 over and the house
exceeds to that
language at the bottom of the page
138 there is section 195 and I think
they change on that
is oh
at the bottom of page 143 and again this
cleans up the language for the revolving
funds that needed to be done that the
house had deleted only because the
governor had originally told us they
didn't need them so the house is
exceeding to that
language which brings us
to page
144 and we are happily back into
language that is the
same on page
145 section
198 cleans up rsas and one RSA reference
has been corrected the house exceeds to
that section 199
is a council on resources and
development that the house didn't have
but it was there and the house exceeds
to that we are now moving
to oops I flipped the page going the
wrong
way that's the page
yeah 148 and I can't it flip shut when I
moved it
around okay page 148 representative wlo
you wanted to discuss the chief engineer
which apparently doesn't exist
anymore well I believe that the
makeup I believe the makeup of the
Public Utilities Commission should be
one engineer one accountant and one
lawyer that's where it was for many
years and now they're taking out the
engineer I think it's very important
that we have an engineer in that on that
board I was told that the chief engineer
was out because there hadn't been one
for quite a while I believe that's
correct but could we hear from the
governor's office on
that so there's no even chief engineer
position allocated to this agency is
that what you're telling
me do you want to ask him to confirm
that and hold it representative wer yes
sure and if I could just point out this
has to do not with the appointment of
the commission but relative to
Prohibition on employment after leaving
the commission and so it removes that
prohibition from the chief engineer
position as opposed to removing the
chief engineer all it does is remove a
Prohibition from that chief engineer uh
relative future employment does that
make you feel
better yes can we
exceed we can exceed the house exceeds
to the Senate language Chris you don't
have a lunchtime task
now we'll we'll come up with something
else
all right we are again going through
pages of Department of energy where the
house and the Senate
were in complete agreement on page
156 section
deletes one position the house would
like to understand
why
was this did this come from the
governor to the Senate asking for the
change so this came from the governor to
the
Senate there an objection to exceeding
house
members no the house succeeds to the
Senate page
158 site evaluation goes back to normal
page 160 is a reference change that was
corrected is that correct Mr Kane
correct the house exceeds to the
reference
change okay on bottom of page 162
section 236 was amended you'll find that
change on the bottom of page26 and
basically what they have done is they
have scratched commission and added at
164 and changed it to Department of
energy and the house exceeds to that
language oh my friends we get to the
page of top of page
168 the house would like to hold on that
I have an amend M Mr
Kaine could we just pass the amendment
out for the Senate to have to look at
over there L yes we will pass that on
that's amendment
901h I don't want you to fall on the
floor and get a red face right here in
front of everybody
why that's because I don't like
continually appropriated when there's a
vet so if I could make a suggestion to
this amendment that you could um I would
be okay with this uh representative over
as long as there was a sentence added to
it that
expedited um the Pu coming to
fiscal Mr Kane could we add
that
I knew you were going to get me on
there my personal pet
peeve so he would like
to yes if you just um sorry if you want
uh Madam chair uh I will give you that
sentence after lunch okay let's do that
after lunch we can
hold
okay we now are back to flipping Pages
where we were in total
agreement we get to page
172 and this is a minor change but when
the house looked through these many
pages and many sections we failed to
notice that the expenses of the office
of commissioner Advocate which are
currently being paid have been left out
the Senate has added that and the house
will exceed to the
Senate on page
175 we have section
248 and all the Senate changed in that
was to add the words or the department
to clarify the
language we will
exceed
to the
Senate
and yes it was the following
page and then we are on page
177 Senate section 251 which relates to
house section
242 the house had repealed the ru making
authority of the Public Utilities
Commission the Senate eliminated that
but Mr Kaine they added paragraph two
can you tell us what that does
please I would defer to the governor's
office that was a request by the
governor's office
okay Mr Elms you're up
again okay told you we'd find
one okay we will hold
on Section 251 pending and
explanation section
252 adds or the department on page
178 and
the house exceeds or 179 to the Senate
position again it's Clarity of
who's doing what in this new
Department we now
go on
page
184 we had a house SE section number
250 rights and public Waters and
lands and the Senate did not move that
across Mr Kane can you explain
that this could be another lunchtime
task but I will explain um so we're
request by the governor's office but the
request was to leave RSA 3711 17b as is
um with maintaining the reference to the
commission instead of changing that to
the Department of energy relative to uh
polls
Mr
Elms okay that's out we're okay with
that
right
yeah
okay moving
on we're now on page
188 and we have small
clarifications the house had the
commission or under its direction the
Senate added or under the direction of
the commission or the department of
energy the house exceeds to that small
language
change on the bottom of
page
191 we have section 270 which was
amended by the
Senate but that
change shows
up really on page
196 where the Senate did not include the
public interest pay phones that the
house had so is this Mr Elms is this a
you want to talk to this or can Mr Caine
do
this I assume this was a Governor's
request
represent
wer question for a while there was a
charge on our phone bills to support
these public interest pay phones has
that been removed or will it be removed
in the
future so probably future
repeal thank
you anybody else represent Burger thank
you madam chair he said the dedicated
fund had been
repealed I believe he did Mr elms did
you say the dedicated fund had been
repealed
yes yes that is chapter 19 of the 21
session that was formerly House Bill
134 so basically we're saying that in
the state of New Hampshire there will be
no more
pays no more public interest
pays I don't care what they are
payones I don't think
it's Mr Kane do you have any idea I
believe it was a fund relative to public
interest specific pay phones that hasn't
been used it was inactive for several
years and so as part of the dedicated
fund uh Review Committee um they removed
that specific dedicated fund but didn't
change any other statute relative to
payones
so you might so what you're saying is
that it was only the public interest pay
phones and not all pay
phones yes correct for that fund correct
Mr hel Elms is also shaking his head
yes okay thank you not that I use them
but I might okay this past the Senate
and the house agrees with that
change so that brings us to page 19
8 I've been ask to remind everybody to
pull your microphones close to you
somehow it's not going out to the world
and we have these big books in front of
us so that makes it a little difficult
but we'll do the best we can thank you
Erin we had investigative orders which
came to us from the
governor and it was removed and I assume
that removal is because it came to the
Senate that we didn't need this Mr Elms
can
you say is that
true all right the house then is okay
with that wasn't there to start with so
we're on page
200202 no
changes we get to the bottom of page
204 this was amended by the Senate and I
think the change is on page
209 Mr Kaine they removed some language
The house's question was was that
language in an RSA or was it just an
order uh it was in an RSA and I believe
this was um Senator Bradley of Rose MD
relative to a pu former pu order that is
they still wanted to refer to because
it's uh this has to do with uh
commission order number 25932 dated
August 2nd 2016 relative to Energy
Efficiency resource standard uh that's
in current RSA now the house had I think
based on discussions with the government
had removed that the senate had an
amendment to add that remove that strike
through basically to so maintain it as
the current statute
reads so we still have legis ative
approval of the New Hampshire general
court is that what the law the line
above that says and that is true that's
correct so if I might yes please um we
were confused so when the
um legislature weighed in in terms of
approval of any change or the systems
benefits charge in the in the future it
Exempted this order for the Energy
Efficiency resource standard so any new
program that had a um change in the
systems benefits charge would have to be
approved by the full legislature but not
the E okay so we still have full
legislative approval of changes to the
system benefits charge the restoration
of yeah and if I could go back the going
way back when um to the restructuring
statute the legislature gave explicit
authority to the Pu at that time to move
forward with changes to the systems
benefits charge so what we did I think
you and I worked on this together
representative over a couple of years
ago took that authorization back but the
eers was under full pu Authority okay so
since we still have full legislative
approval which is what we want and we
can see that on the Senate side there is
a sentence saying
that the house will exceed to the Senate
change all right we're now flipping
Pages where we once again are in total
agreement language is 100% the
same there was no
no comparable house
section for the electric utility
restructuring rate payer protection I
think it's pretty clear but Mr Kane
could you just walk us through that so
we're sure we
understand sorry yes so on page 217
27 uh section
282 uh those were further reference
changes that were needed because of the
EST estblished under the department of
energy so you can see the department of
energy being rep um the commission being
replaced by the department of energy in
several instances and that was their
Governor's request okay thank you the
house will exceed to
that we're
now zipping through Page 220 on page
221 we have some
changes
and I assume that this came also from
the governor when the house had
it this
they the offshore wind industry remained
in Department of Business and economic
Affairs when the Senate got it that was
scratched and it was added to the
Department of
energy was that a Governor's request
again Mr Mr Hoffman saying yes all right
the house will exceed to that change
we are now on page
223 and there's section
289 and the actual change on
that is found on
224 and the house had the commission may
establish requirements and what the
Senate did was clean up the language and
say consistent with their statutory
Authority the commission and the
department of energy May establish
requirements and then the rest of the
language is the same so the house
exceeds to
that on page 291 at the bottom of page
224 the Senate added and the department
of
energy and the house exceeds to
that page 225 which is section
292 you see on page
226 the house said if it and the Senate
added if the commission
determines which clarifies the language
and the house exceeds to
that
okay we have moved to page
230 and we
have the business profits tax single
sales factor which the Senate has no
comparable Amendment
on the house would like to discuss the
house sections that were not included
representative nor major who chairs Ways
and Means this was a ways and means
request to add to the house so Norm do
you want to join us at the table
again
Floy sh represent
major the single sales Factor
the
house um agreed to the single sales
Factor but to be
implemented not now but in the future
years the primary reason for that is
that the data that's required to know
how much it's going to affect us positiv
or negatively is not available the best
estimate we have with the
Dr is $20 million if we implement it now
so as it stands it would cost us $20
million if this is
removed Senator moris yeah the Senate
did account for several things that they
adopted in their budget um we did
account for this $20 million in our
budget is it 20 million every year
fiscal year 23 so the Senate base
estimates assumed current law which
included this uh single sales Factor um
so just in begins in 23 but I don't
believe I'll turn around to Chris I
don't believe it's 20 million a year
like going forward into 24 and 25 um
I'll see if Chris can add anything it's
probably indeterminable as
representative major knows because this
is a really tough area for ways means to
get their uh handle around Dr as well
when they analyze returns but Chris can
fill you in on the conversation that so
nice of you to put Chris on The Hot Spot
well done yes did he he's still there's
still there he's running out of the room
now I think might cover that and it is
indeterminable in the out years the
house Ways and Means had an estimate of
$20 million in 23 as the impact based on
some data that they had received from Dr
um but there was still a number of
questions and that's why they had asked
for the um change in law to have it take
effect um two years later so in
2025 represent
wer so did did the senate make a
determination based upon the money or is
this been a request from the
corporations that we go to a single
sales factor and would it be a simpler
way for the Dr to to compute
figures um both they we certainly heard
that businesses wanted us to account for
this and we were in the position
that we could account for this we
accounted for payroll protection and
several other things in the Senate
budget um I I I would venture to say the
discussions that are going to go on
tomorrow and on are going to be about
all the money senate had to account for
and to account for tax reductions um I
think was probably the best way to do
things thank
you does the house want to hold this so
you can have another
discussion I think it's worth holding
okay the house will hold these
sections these sections go through
Section uh go through to page
236 on page
236 the house had the equivalent of
House Bill
626 historical horse racing that passed
the house house it passed the Senate it
has been signed into law so it was
removed from
hb2 and you will see that that goes
through
pages
242 where we get
to section
296 that was the house section 302 and
we were in agreement
there then we get
to don't go away
Norm we get to the top of page
243 we had again added a section at the
request of house Ways and Means on a
bill they had starting with Section 303
and
304 is the decision we're doing away
with the history historic horse
racing that has been signed into law is
that correct that is correct and the
senate had removed those sections so no
further action is they removed the
sections because it was a law and you
announced that we exceeded it no I said
they removed it I just went through it I
didn't say one way or the other they
took it out so there weren't any
sections I was just explaining people at
home trying to figure out what we're
doing yeah was a little difficult so
this was a bill that way means had
starting with Section
Norm I would suggest we hold this is
because almost looks like a bill that
was passed last
year and um we're doing research on it
now okay I
is
I thought we passed it last year and you
guys found some things to clean up I'm
trying to remember I know I talked to
representative AB brami when you guys
asked to put it in because I got the
data from him but I'm happy to hold this
we come back to it
okay we will do
that okay
that actually goes through several pages
and we've put the whole thing while
representative
major talks about
it Mr Kaine the house is going to at
this time hold section
through 299 I think it is and we have an
amendment that is too soon to discuss
but needs to be passed out and given
to everyone that's Amendment
2021 d19
35h it's several pages so it's too much
to try to go through right here
everybody needs to have it to think
about and read we can distribute that
now
please
thank you I have one I'll just give this
to
truck do you have one representative
over Excuse me yes we put sections
203 what page are we on representive
hurger
uh
243 we're on page
243 yeah thank you ma'am and it's
um 240 it's page
through three uh page 244 those those
are all the things that section 316 317
all those go together yeah page
um page 248 goes with that
bill all of those represent major asked
to hold so we can talk about he's going
to do a little research
okay
so which I'm sorry I'm still not clear
as to which items are on
hold he is just ask us to hold the
equivalent of the bill that Ways and
Means was working on on the house of
section there is no comparable SE Senate
section did not pass through the Senate
we did have it we're going to let
representative major talk to his team
and do a little research at lunch about
where we are with
that so that should take you to through
Section 313 yeah which is
yeah
and now at the bottom at
256 I think we have a new section but
the change goes to the top at
257 oh no that's still the sections with
297 on
hold
um
section Senate section 301 which was the
house section
332 is the section
that will authorize the governor to draw
a warrant up to
$110,000 during the pandemic there were
multiple emergency
orders high
stress some businesses got fined the
House and Senate agree
to refund those fines and we have agreed
to put that in there the bottom of page
257 the Senate has amended the animal
records
database that the house sent to
them for a couple of
reasons after it passed the house the
Commissioner of Agriculture was notified
in writing by the federal government
that they would no longer do the data
entry they had been doing for him on
this
situation and representative Howard
Pearl who chairs environment and
agriculture worked with the commissioner
worked with Senator Bradley and worked
out language that the Senate has put
into the bill that the house would would
have been agreeable to had that happened
at the time because this was a bill
passed out of Ena and passed by the
house on the floor of the house so these
changes for the animal records database
are small changes that the house agrees
with and the house is going to exceed to
those changes many
sections oh many it goes through through
to
page 264 section
309 nope sorry section 310 for the
effective
dates you see
those
which brings us to dual and concurrent
enrollment
programs
section
331 on page
264 which the Senate amended on page
267 representative umberger could you
talk to us this was a program
that you and your team would have
vetted
yes I'll be right there excuse that's
okay all these Pages back and
forth I can't find it but anyhow two
page
267 267 is the change to what you put in
the rest of it I believe uses your
language and then they added paragraph
two on page
267 and
um basically um I have no problem with
the change that the Senate made uh on
Dual and concurrent
enrollment uh in our committee the um
doe wanted to relinquish their
responsibility for dual and concurrent
enrollment and the Community College was
in favor of picking up that respon
ibility how do you feel about the
language that allows them to
to go to fiscal committee and ask for
more
money I kind of thought we
should budget that appropriately but
division two may feel
differently when we did the budget um we
did not include if I'm not mistaken 10th
grade in the Dual and concurrent
enrollment
program and um that has since been
added through
HB
148 which although it hasn't the final
vote hasn't been there isn't done I and
it's in Committee of conference I'm sure
that that will not change and so that's
that's one of the major re reasons
why uh I think it should be okay to come
to
fiscal and
um we will have money in the education
trust fund
to take care of this I'm not I'm not
particularly worried and we should we
should be able to uh work it
out Senator Morris does the sen have any
comments on this section
piece good
job okay and representative umre this
goes into section 312 right below and
they've added the appropriation shall
not laps is your
team yes we're fine with that okay the
house will exceed to those two
sections
we have arrived at section
272 which I think is the page I'm sorry
page
272 and Section
320 um probably should do
271 section 319 representative un briger
this is something you dealt with and
then we'll
have Mr C talk to us about the changes
but do you have anything to say before
Mr Kane
starts uh yippi yippi okay Mr Kane sure
section 319 besides saying yippy can you
tell us a little bit about sure section
319 um from the Senate there were the
house had appropriated $9 million for
four programs for porman a bridge EMB
betterment fleet vehicles and winter
maintenance um and discussions in the
Senate that was reduced by $8 million to
$1 million and the two programs removed
were the additional a porman a
distributions in the um 4 million for
the fuel winter maintenance
operations and apparently with a loud
yipp be the house is exceeding to the
senate in this
section can I just speak to that fors
seconds um I think it was alluded to the
other day that there were gimmicks um
this was an accounting gimmick that I
put in because there were other places
that made more sense and I've never
funded winter M maintenance to be honest
with you um to the full amount I've
always made them come back to fiscal
because I think we need to understand
where they're going each year so
um to be honest with you I think the
budget has a lot of things like this in
it so um I think it was actually we had
more money to be able to move things
around so and we are jealous when you do
and and I certainly have no problem with
what they did in Winter maintenance um
kind of makes sense for fiscal to be
tracking winter maintenance so we have a
better understanding when we build
budgets right I don't you know I don't
and plus they someplace else they gave
Transportation uh $50 million so it's
not like they won't have the dollars
available if
necessary okay Mr Kane that brings us to
the top of page 272 with Section 320 and
we are going to take a lunch break and
we will be on break until one o'clock
so
hopefully it's nice to see faces in the
audience but hopefully you can find
something to do until one
o'clock okay let's make
that 1:30 two members of the Senate have
another Committee of conference they
need to attend at one is you're welcome
you're very welcome we are in recess
until 130 I mean sorry not recess we're
taking a
break and we will see you after we eat
thank
you
I
know
thank you
Chris looks like you're live we're just
gonna have Scott take down the screen
sharing oh he just did all
right we are
live we're back from our break we had a
nice lunch hope you guys did too
yeah ba is passing out two amendments
that go
together thank
you these are the last two adjustments
on the department of energy and
basically we have
Amendment 202 one-1
904h that
replicates I think it's Senate Bill 85
is that correct Senator Bradley with one
small check change uh yes it is and if
you could point out where the change is
moving it to um Bureau of economic
Affairs Mr Kane can you point that out
for
us we're moving the Broadband to Bea
away
[Music]
from Department of
energy
someplace
they're
talking I think this is a brand new
section
um creating the Broadband matching Grant
initiative the Senate Bill 85 I believe
it is uh created it under the um office
of strategic initiatives was it OSI was
OSI and dbea this would create an to the
new Department of energy since DBA is
going away no we did that you did that
we did that in s sp85 okay we need to
move it to
Bea uh I'm not sure this does that no
I'm not either yeah
dbea with the new Department of energy
would not be existing anymore um Bureau
of economic Affairs yeah is now getting
the planners from OSI they didn't move
to Department of energy and it is the
planners that will handle the Broadband
that correct that's what you and I have
agreed to I think that's what the
governor's office
wants okay we'll have to redraft this
then uh 1904 does not do
that Jeb do we trust them to do that go
ahead with the next one yes okay we will
do that so we'll put that aside and
we'll go
to 202 one-1
1942 which transfers one position from
one accounting unit to another
accounting unit within the department of
energy and Madam chair I will um move
the
amendment um I will just say this I
think I I think that um as with the
creation of any new Department there may
need to be some changes agree um in the
future you and I have agreed that we'll
if the general counsel position needs
further work we'll look at it as
required
absolutely Senator Bradley moves the
adoption of amendment 2012 one-1 1942 is
there a second
second represent wer seconds on the
house side if you're in favor please
raise your
hands the Senate
side motion passes unanimously Mr
K Y we are
now I
believe on page
Section
320 and this
section makes an appropriation to the
Department of
Education for school building a we're
putting 30 million
after a long Hiatus in school building
Aid it increases the amount the house
had because again the senate had more
money and the house has agreed to exceed
to this
language and to section
321 section 322 at the bottom of the
page has no change we've already moved
it
on we have some concerns with Section
324 representative umberger do you want
to talk to this this is we're on page
273 this is just the change of an
effective date of the previous
section yes um the reason that we use
the 1 April date in
22 is because this is the first time
that Dr will be able to make the
adjustments they're well aware of what
uh what needs to be done but the actual
time when they send out to the
communities how much they have to pay in
uh Statewide property tax occurs in
April of
22 and that's why we use that
date we had all kinds of other
dates that we we were looking at but uh
that was the one that uh worked for Dr
Mr Kane can you help us shed any lights
as well I we understand what
representative hurger and her team did
and I don't know exactly where we
are can have Mickey answer that question
for
you he just went to lunch I
think well I'm looking at it now um back
with the fiscal n worksheet that we
received from Dr on House Bill 2 as
passed by the house they did identify a
technical concern with the date of the
effective of those sections being April
1 2022 that would be the date of the the
warrant for the reduction of the swep
would be reflected then I think they had
just hoped that the effective date of
that law would be sooner so they could
actually use it when they calculate out
that warrant so that was a technical
correction uh that was made at the uh
with information Dr provided so
basically they needed they asked to have
the date changed so that they felt
comfortable working on it before it was
due is that what correct correct yeah
this would not this date rate this date
um change does not impact when the rate
would or excuse me the uh amount would
would not change the amount of the $100
million reduction in fiscal 23 it just
would allow them to calculate it in
advance okay thank you I'm sorry I I
should have asked Mick no problem in
that case the house will exceed yep to
the change in section
324 section
325 on the bottom of page 273 actually
has the
change on
374 so you have to flip your book
around we we had some concerns with
this Mr Kaine the house felt like this
was going to pay people for child care
when they weren't putting their children
in child child care but we're keeping
them at
home can you help us understand that um
I would defer to the Senate to answer
that on why that was added
okay back to you
guys Senator rosenal thank you um I
think I my mic on the Senate's thinking
was that this is only for children that
are actually enrolled in a Child Care
Program um but it would allow the
centers to be res reimbursed for the
days that the
child's couldn't come in because someone
in the family was Ill or
quarantining or the child was sick
itself the department did do this um at
least briefly during part of last year
um during the stay at home but it does
not complement it doesn't contemplate
children that aren't enrolled because
their parents are not at
work or of Edwards do you want to move
to the table to talk are we
okay need a micone yes so representative
turot will happily yield his
seat
thank you representative turkot for
letting me have your seat for a moment
and thank you madam chair I I would say
on this subject that while I can
appreciate um how uh an enrollment based
payment method would help the people
receiving the funds uh I I I do think
that we ought to keep it at um actual
attendance policy
uh I think as we look at the future we
should look at a bright happy future we
have the pandemic increasingly behind us
and we shouldn't continue to anticipate
things like quarantines and major
shutdowns so I I would recommend to my
colleagues and my friends in the Senate
that we move this back to an
attendance-based policy and not
enrollment represent bumberger did I see
you had a
question yes I did
um how how is uh tanith paid
now is it based on the days they attend
or is it based on the
um the fact that
they're signed
up the child care reimbursement is based
on the days that children are there
right
now thank you Senator Morris would the
Senate exceed to the house
language Senate would like to hold we
will put this section on
hold it's no surprise ladies and
gentlemen that we have some issues with
the cunu center you presented and took
out ours so
um we're going to do some discussion of
that which I think is going to include
all of your sections and you start on
page 280 with Section
327 and Mr Kane how far does that go
sure so I believe this goes from section
326 on page uh
274 all the
way
through Section 330 on page
okay and 330 continues on to page 282 as
well what
about what do we have with Section
331 ah yes the closed loop referral
we're on page
283 the house exceeds to the
Senate on this
language did you hold on the sen Center
yes we
held thank you for the
clarification and we exceed on page to
two 331 the closed loop
system and in return I thank you for
adding section
332 how section
332 if you live in a sen a town that has
enacted Senate Bill two form of
government will allow your towns to be
able to spend money coming from the arpa
plan so the house is delighted to exceed
to this
section
the
so we're we're happy whoever did it
salary schedules Mr Kane this is can you
explain section 333 hous had no such
section sure section 333 through 354
which begins on page 284 is relative to
the um state employee pay rise which was
uh ratified by the various barting
groups uh after the house had
finished so the house will exceed to
that and that brings us to
page
correct we did not have this comparable
section is
355 did that come out of the new labor
contract this was actually I believe
Senator rosenal offered this amendment
but it's in addition of a boiler plate
section that had been in there relative
to how any positions if there were
layoffs uh which which aren't contained
in this budget but there is a certain
process uh that they have to follow so
this is something that typically is
included in house bill to that was not
included yet would you like to speak to
your section Senator
rosenal and please pull the mic close
people you have a soft voice and people
having a hard time hearing no
problem
the house will exceed to this
language we would like to hold on the
section beginning
356 and how far does this section go Mr
Kaine this's go several Pages several
sections uh 356 through 361 begins on
page 292 and ends on page
306 okay we're going to hold
on those section
ctions that brings us to 362 on page 306
Mr Kane can you walk us through this
please sure this is a section that the
department of administrative Services
had approached the Senate relative to uh
annual and sickly for unclassified
executive PL employees um I think this
is something that the department polies
will help them recruit and fill the
unclassified position
uh which allows the formerly classified
employees to maintain any leave that
they accumulated prior to transferring
to that unclassified
position as I understand the current
law if you switch from classified
unclassified you lose all your ACR sick
time and vacation time they pay you for
it but you no longer have in case you
get the flu or something you no longer
have any builtup time that you can stay
home is that correct correct
unclassified don't earn leave time so uh
I believe you'll be paid if you left
that position unless it's retirement you
paid your annual and your comp time uh
as well any bonus leave um this allows
them to carry forward your annual comp
and your sick to that unclassified
position so that in the event you retire
from that unclassified position when you
retire you can be paid for that service
and use
that thoughts of the
house the house will exceed to the
Senate turning to page 307 we now are
all in into sections that the house did
not
have so
307 does that go along with what we were
just discussing Mr Kane it does sections
362 through 365 which begins on page 306
and goes through Page 307 um are all
related to what we just discussed the
next section uh would be relative to a
366 which is a new section on the bottom
of page 308 that was added by the Senate
relative to abolished positions uh which
states that any position that was uh
remained was vacant on July 1st 2018 and
remains fake and shall be abolished by
September 30th it does provide uh the
governor to provide exceptions as
necessary um and then a follow-up report
to the fiscal committee on how many
positions were
impacted so if you're position was
vacant prior to July 1st
201118 2018 and three years later it's
still vacant it's gone the money's gone
budgets are reduced cor correct the
house exceeds to this language do did
you say we have a preliminary on how
many positions this might
affect uh Senator Daniels may have the
number
um hundreds of positions um I believe
this could impact it could be several
million dollars potentially not
necessarily General funds these are
various federal funds other funds
Etc section 367 which is on page
309 is a section that the agricultural
commi commissioner mentioned to us when
he met with us in division one however
we didn't have any money so we didn't go
ahead with it this now appropriates the
sum of
$100,000 to the cost of care fund for
the Department of Agriculture markets
and
food and we will exed to the governor to
the H Senate on this and it goes along
with Section
369 this is the new data manager
position is this the position Mr Kain
that after the federal government sent
written notice to the Commissioner of
Agriculture that they would no longer do
the data in entry he had to have this
position that is correct relative to the
dairy program and the house will exceed
to the Senate on that page and that
section and if there's
a continuation no that ends it all right
we get to page
310 section 370 another new section can
you talk us about to us about this Mr
Kane sure these were two positions um
that the the Attorney General requested
um position
reclassification relative to um there's
an attorney 2 position transfer to
Department of Justice and 21 from HHS as
well as um another position U related to
an Assistant Attorney General being
abolished so this was an attorney
general's request that the Senate did
approve questions from the
house is this a pay
raise uh this
there are no dollars associated with
this reclassification in this particular
item we okay with this
guys okay the house exceeds to the
Senate Mr Kane can you talk to us
about 371 and 372
please sure 371 and
372 um I'm blanking on the um Senate
Bill uh that went through that created
the National Guard enlistment incentive
program um the language from that Senate
bill I believe it was Senate Bill 43 or
143 was added to House Bill too in
addition to a um an appropriation of
$25,000 which you can find on Section
377 on page 312 and this is for the
National Guard enlistment incentive uh
you will see if I stay on page
312 uh you will see the bottom or at the
in the top block that the fines um
relative to the state treasur credited
to New Hampshire National Guard
Recruitment and Retention scholarship
fund uh has been removed and I believe I
don't believe that program was funded in
the budget but I'll confirm with Mike
Coffman that's correct the scholarship
program had no appropriation in the
budget request and this program replaces
the former uh National Guard scholarship
program so we're going to repeal the
scholarship program and replace it for
the same amount with an incentive
program to try to incent people and they
had been dis they had discovered because
they do get free tuition at the
University and the community colleges
that they didn't need the scholarship
program so the house will exceed to
those
sections uh Mr Kane we are on page 313
so that will take you and we have to
shift this and now we have some new
sections from the insurance department
that the house did not
see yes they did um establish um some
additional positions in the insurance
department a director of life and health
um with the salary determined by um RSA
941a which is the joint legislative
employee classification committee as
well as the position of director
property in casualty and with insurance
no General funds would be
involved and what about section 380 does
that relate to this yes I'm sorry
section 380 on page 314 also relates to
section
379 okay the house will exceed to that
language which brings us to
381 yep section 381 on page 314
appropriates $200,000 22 and $200,000 23
to the business Finance Authority for
providing equal grants to Regional
Economic Development
corporations and what does that mean
I'll defer to the Senate on that
sure uh thank you very much Madam chair
this money is for the administrative
costs of the regional Development
Corporation
um the
rdc's operate both a loan and grant
program or small
businesses um Jack Cy in art neck of the
woods um is one of the 10 rdc's
so this was why the Senate chose to fund
it okay house
okay the house will exceed to the Senate
language moving us quickly along to page
P
3155 page 315 of section 382 this is a
$25 million appropriation from fiscal
year 21 to the Housing Finance
authorities affordable housing
fund I think
many committees in both the house and
the Senate hear from people on the lack
of affordable housing and making
affordable housing um a b ailable in the
state is this
appropriation to be spent in this fiscal
year or this fiscal
bium this would be non-aps so based on
the timing of the passage of the budget
would be for future years
okay the house is going to exceed to the
Senate on 382 and
383 we have a new section from
dnrc
384 Mr Kane give us the background on
this sure section 384 was added by an
amendment from Senator Hennessy she was
contract uh contacted by uh the Bureau
of certain Trail organizations in her
area uh this has to do there's no cost
associated with this what it does is it
allows any grant and aid provided so
basically snowmobile or ohrv fees that
are given to these
organizations um it caps what they can
be used for it moves that cap from in
some instances 60 to 70% up to 90% And
so it it's no additional funds it's just
how the funds uh may be used and granted
to those
organizations represent
vber thank you um Mr Kane the the way
it's written it says it's only for ohrv
Trails is that a a mistake or are we
because there are snowmobile trails that
do not follow o ohrv rules so I'm I'm a
little concerned that uh if it's only
ohrv that's one thing but if it's both
then obviously I like
it better than you like it
now yeah I would have to say it's not Mr
Kane what is your thought sure we can um
talk to Senator Hennessy to uh just
ensure that that was not a mistake that
was intentional and and I I'll have to
do a stat story search relative to the
definition of ohrv Trails um or mik
coffin might be able to add something
think yes this amendment was intended to
be specific to
hrvs and not snow not both just the hrvs
do you know why
I do not know why but I do know
initially it was drafted with both and
then it was changed to be only applying
to
ohvs represent vurger would you like to
hold on this while you do a little
research while I get annoyed yes okay we
we'll hold on this so you don't get
annoyed oh this next one is dandy I keep
waiting for Hudson to get $220,000 from
State okay can you explain this to me
sure sections 385 and 386 on page
315 appropriates $20,000 in fiscal year
21 to the Hampton Beach area commission
uh this would be
non-lps can the senate tell us what
they're going to do with
that
Senator Morris is not in the room but
this was something that was brought
forward to him
by Hampton Beach
commission
sen represent wer I think I remember
something about electrical connections
no that was in the Parks we took that
out play paid for it with ar
money Morris is back Senator Morris can
you Enlighten us a little bit on Hampton
Beach yeah you might want to leave again
[Laughter]
okay oh I know where it is and I know
how much it is and I 20,000 in section
385 on page 315 uh and this is not
jokingly I uh I wouldn't go to wakes um
the uh Senator Styles asked that we uh
help Hampton Beach out and the um she
made a request of $20,000 in order to
create this master fund um and it's
probably the least request that Senator
Senator Styles has ever asked for that's
for sure Hampton and um the uh we said
we'd agree to it in the Senate house are
we okay I'm okay yeah we will exceed to
this all right Mike we're dipping right
along yes section three that brings you
to section 387 on page 316 actually
sections 387 and 388 this is relative to
an appropriation of approximately $3
million uh for the soal granite Shield
program I have an amendment on that
someplace yes you do we can hand that
out oh that would be lovely
I don't even I don't even have to read
this I know exactly what it
says thank you
M okay basically what this does is it
confirms and expands
into the section that's added on page
two Granite Shield is used to help law
enforcement cut down on drugs in our
state and the legislature believes it
should cover the entire program because
once the arrest is made many of those
people use public defenders that money
is paid out of the judicial
Council and we have in the past if you
brought in a grant that wasn't in the
budget provided 5% of the grant to go to
public defenders so that judicial
Council would not have to come back to
fiscal and say well you didn't fund me
again so this section two makes it clear
that for granite
Shield 5% of any additional funds not
just federal grants will go to the
public defender so that there is defense
without running that budget into the
red Senator Bradley yes uh thank you
very much so if I'm understanding this
amendment correct irly uh this would not
subtract anything from the initial I
think it's $3 million Grant but it would
be any additional funds over and above
that that would go toward the public
defender is that correct I'm going Mr
landang kindly wrote this and I'm going
to let him give you an answer that will
be 100% correct instead of me just
agreeing and turning out it
wasn't I would say the way this is
drafted the 5% would be from the the
appropriation in section 387 if if the
intent would be to have an additional
it's approximately $150,000 is the 5% is
what that represents that would be above
and beyond the three million already in
uh house bill
to I'm okay with that if you guys are
okay with that Senator rosenal I have a
question um about the insert
language does this mean that if the
judicial Council came to fiscal and said
we need another $100,000 of General
funds to pay for Indigent defense if we
gave it to them they'd be putting
$5,000 into
that fund so we would be
transferring General funds from just one
place to another to the best of my lot
knowledge judicial Council does not have
dedicated funds so it goes into their
budget line items for General
funds yes so in this instance what would
happen Senator is um of the just assumed
3 million the 5% is deducted from this
new $3 million uh that would provide an
additional
$150,000 to the judicial Council over
and above what's budgeted in house bill
one so it should uh alleviate the need
for them to come to fiscal for that 150
thank
you so Madam chair I would move to
accept your Amendment with a additional
amendment to ensure that these are
additional funds not from the existing
Granite Shield grant that would be fine
with me Mr landan can we make that
happen without waiting for paperwork yep
we can do that okay is there a second
second if the house is in favor please
raise your
hands we are unanimous Senator
mois Senate is
unanimous and with that
addition we accept um
lines sorry sections 387 and 388 and it
brings us to section 389 the fire
standards and training and Emergency
Medical Services fund correct which
continues on page
317 yes section 389 uh goes along with
390 and to summarize those two actions
the first section
389 appropriates an additional 30
$100,000 a fiscal year into the fire
standards and training and EMS fund from
the general fund so that's a general
fund cost that's uh reflected in the
Senate Surplus statement section 390 as
a result of those additions additional
funds section
390 appropriates $200,000 from the fire
fund which has now just been um received
that additional 300 and that is
specifically for the purpose of funding
additional part-time instruction uh and
providing discounts to the those uh send
those fire um departments that are
sending uh trainees here so this avoided
a need for uh tuition
increase representative bumberger this
is your team I understand you are in
agreement with this
absolutely the house will exceed to the
language in these two sections which
brings us Mr Kane to section 391 I sense
another yippe coming out of
Representative
hurger sure section 391 is a a general
fund transfer to the highway fund of $50
million in fiscal year 22 as Senator
Moore stated uh the Senate Revenue
estimates were higher due to collections
in April and projected collections in
May and June uh that left a significant
sum in the general fund at the end of 22
which the Senate decided to transfer to
the highway fund um since the highway
fund ending balance was under a million
dollars um projected at the end of 23
this Shores up the highway fund Senator
Morris yeah the um it's probably worth
making the point here because I I read
an article about how much money the
senate had in
21 um there's $50 million to put into
the highway fund here the next line that
you're going to read about is 7 million
we put into the highway fund which will
free up an additional in total 29
million um in the highway fund when they
work with Washington on that line um
along with that um um it was mentioned
earlier that there's money in the
education trust fund it's about 24
million until we pass something that
Lottery asked us to do um and there's
155 million plus um because I do believe
revenues are going up going to be in the
rainy day fund so when people are
looking for where hundreds of millions
of dollars ended up um I wouldn't just
look to the spend lines we the Senate
spent a lot of time trying to fill
buckets um that will protect money for
the
future this is one of them and uh I
think everybody knows I have
F we do
this and this um I'll add to that with
every car getting seems like better
mileage every year hybrid cars all
electric cars we're not getting the gas
tax we used to get which was what filled
the highway fund and then last year we
had people who just didn't commute we
all stayed home not just in this state
but in other state we used to have a lot
of people ride from here to
Massachusetts and back and forth and
that was big income for the highway
funding that was entirely
gone Senator Mor I would just suggest I
made this clear earlier um that
representative major send his program to
the federal government because they're
contemplating fixing that electric car
situation and representative Maes
program I think would work nationally so
if he would have send it there um
they're looking for a funding source
right now so um I'm sure you could send
it to the US senators and it probably
would work to solve the problem they're
trying to Sol yep represent major for
those of you who don't know has spent
hours trying to work out how to make
Road repairs and Bridge repairs
Equitable as we go to hybrid intellect
electric vehicles so he's to be
commended for that the house will exceed
to section 391 in section 392 by with
the $7 million we actually free up I
think it's 29 million in the highway
fund because this is something that the
state owes the federal government gets
it off the books reduces State liability
so it just improves our bond rating and
anything we can do to do that and we are
exceeding to that as well as section
393 Madam chair this
actually well we've all been working on
another committee with federal funds and
everything this was something we
researched um this actually sends 29
million back to New Hampshire after we
pay off Our obligation oh excellent so
we get 29 million more for paying off
the obligation that's even
better oh Mike 394 we're going to remove
toll booth sure section 394 and 39 4A
would remove um the exit 10 uh toll from
the Fe return Pike in the town of
marac and we'd already voted that no
tolls would be correct collected there
so the house will exceed to both of
those
sections can you brief us on
395 sure section
395 is a an appropriation of $3.25
million in school year 22 for the
purpose of funding a reconstruction and
reclassification project of a 2-mile
road uh caleff Hill Road in the town of
Tilton is this the road that the
Veteran's Home is on I believe it's an
access to the veterans home it's one of
the roads that you can access the
veterans home
from the house will exceed to this
section that brings us down to 397
section
396 is a general fund appropriation of
$5 million in fiscal year 22 and the
purpose of this appropriation as well as
an appropriation contained for the uh
Port Authority of 4 million in 25 allows
the state to access 20 plus million of
federal funds which they were um able to
leverage with Appropriations but could
not use Turnpike toll credits which is
the typical match uh so this would bring
in the 5 million plus the 4,25 would
bring in I think in over $25 million of
additional federal funds okay so this
cash match gets us more than $25 million
into the state we will exceed to section
396 and that brings us to 397 which
starts on 318 goes to
319 yes section
397 on 318 and uh 398 is relative to an
appropriation that was provided uh to
HHS previous banum for child welfare uh
this allows the that appropriation not
to lapse until the end of fiscal year 22
so no additional money would allow the
money to not lapse and that would be
available until the end of 22 so we're
extending the end date that's correct
puron of Edwards were yeah the house
will exceed to 397
398 and now we are at
399 starts on 319 goes into 320 Mr
Kane sure I may turn to
um Kevin Ripple I believe this was a
change requested by the office of child
advocate if I'm not mistaken Kevin do
you have any background on that sure uh
sections 399 through 402 actually
incorporate aort portion of Senate Bill
157 uh and they just change reporting
requirements for the system of care for
children's Behavioral Health so all you
see here are some new requirements being
added and some statutory references
being changed to reflect the new
requirements what happened to Senate
Bill
157 uh the Senate laid it on the table
obviously for the purpose of putting it
in the budget thank you and what this is
um it's to implement sen a bill 4 which
was the child system of care which I
think we've all seen what's happened
during Co to kids and mental health um I
think the department was in the process
before um Co struck of starting to stand
up the program um obviously it got
interrupted um protecting this lapse
make sure it
does in the end get
implemented
representative Edwards would you like to
join us to the table representative
umberger had to step out uh can can we
just hold this one you can hold this if
you
want we will hold
this
okay so we that brings us to page 321
Mike yes I don't know what's on 321 well
we have some
more yes system of care go goes all the
way to section 402 so those will be put
on hold you want to hold all those
representative Edwards yes
please sure that will bring you to uh
sections 403 and 404 which is an
additional appropriation to HHS for
their contracts and procurement unit uh
it's a full-time classified positions
it's the sum of about uh in total funds
uh about $1.4 million appropriated for
that
purpose what is the pleasure of the
house represent Edwards would like to
hold 403 and
404 that will bring us to page
322 yes so page
322 Senate sections 405 through
uh7 is relative to the supplemental
nutritional assist nutrition assistance
program uh the snap incentive program it
is a $150,000 appropriation for the next
B Anum for the purpose of uh snap I
believe this has to do with uh fresh
fruits and vegetables at farmstands this
is a bill that the house also has I
believe we had a public hearing and we
have it retained what is your pleasure
now representative Edwards I'd like toed
and thank Senator Hennessy for picking
this up okay the house will exceed to
405 and
406 which relates and 407 which
relates and that turns us to page
323 sure page 323 at the top of 323
Senate section 40 8 this is an extension
of I believe it's pres of Eligibility
under the Medicaid Program through the
end of the bium um that was requested by
the
department actually could I just sure
Kevin can clarify this one actually
relates to um access to the state's
Behavioral Health System back in
2011 there was language put in statute
uh for budgetary reasons saying that
access would be limited to available
Appropriations but the language that
passed also included a prospective
repeal so originally two years later uh
that language was to be repealed and
access would once again be unrestricted
for budgetary reasons every two years
the state has extended the repeal date
so by not including this language the
house would
have allowed the repeal to go into
effect and the Senate once again extends
it for another two years
representative
Edwards uh we discussed this in division
three and we thought that uh all good
things must come to an end and we were
willing to let this end the Senate has
differed do you want to hold uh we can
hold Mr Kane section 409 section 409 is
relative to cost of living adjustments
and Social Security benefits under the
social services block
Grant Kevin do you have anything to add
on that one
or Y this um allows the department
to implement the cost of living
adjustment without going to the Joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules every six
months Edwards I think we're can acceed
to this the house will exceed to 409
thank you 410 please section 410 is
relative to presumptive eligibility for
Home and Community Based care services
uh suspended for the bay any meting June
30th
23 represent
Edwards I think we can acceed house will
exceed to
410 411
please section 411 I think I'll turn to
Kevin it establishes a committee uh
relative to Social Security uh waiver
programs but um can you add anything
Kevin I don't have any more information
it would study uh wage parody among
different provider
groups I I don't remember any discussion
on this so I I'd like to hold
please this is Senator Rosen yes this is
um something that Senator GAA and I
worked on during committee with the
organizations that provide services to a
variety of Medicade waiver programs that
have different reimbursement
rates and sometimes they're providing
the same service but getting paid
differently because of who
the what division they're in of the
department and it would just establish a
committee to look at what rate parity
for the same Services would look
like so if I may we're not spending any
money here we're just studying it and
coming back with recommendations if
that's the case I'm fine I'm fine with
that thank you okay the house will
exceed on Section
412 transitional housing bids sections
412 and 413 which begins on page 3 24
appropriate $6 million in 21 for the
purpose of funding new transitional
housing beds uh for patients with
complex behavioral health conditions in
addition any unspent funds from previous
Appropriations so the previous buum
which I think can amount to up to $2
million will also be available for the
Department May the house will exceed on
those two
sections 414 please sections 414 and
4115 are the necessary sections to
effectuate the uh non-aps of State loan
repayment program funds in 21 in order
to fund 22 and 23 house B one
Appropriations so okay we will exceed to
414 and
4:15 uh okay 414 415 416 and 4177 on
page 325 uh effectuates the changes u in
house bill one recommended and adopted
by the uh CSC for Medicaid services so
any unspent funds at the end of 21 shall
be carried forward into 23 and be
available for expenditure for Medicaid
so this is consistent with the actions
taken in the house bill one the house
will exceed on those two
sections beginning at the bottom of 425
moving to the top of
426 is the forensic psychiatric hospital
correct yeah is there a discussion from
the M committee members
Senor Rosen thank you thank you Madame
chair um this is something that got
started in the current bium where uh we
had appropriated a pretty significant
sum of money but it the project did not
get started the result is it's going to
cost 50% more money but also
um think we should reflect on the fact
that we're changing the policy here and
we will um if we adopt this provision
that the Senate adopted we will be
allowing private prisons to operate the
secure psych
unit the house side representative
Edwards do you have something to say I'm
interested in hearing what Senator
Bradley has to say I I I would just
point out that uh when division three
heard heard about the heard this uh we
decided it was a pretty big project and
we didn't have enough time to decide in
our normal business so we held this
issue over and met in a joint hearing
with public works and HHS afterwards we
I think I think the as a result of that
hearing we learned a lot and and I
believe the department has made a lot of
improvements to their plan but but I I I
I we just missed it without prejudice
hoping that the Senate could use our
information so Senator Bradley and
Senator Morris however you want to go
please go well there's a there's a lot
going
on if you press that down it stays on
okay there's a lot going on here the
first of all we did have more money in
the Senate so there was 8.7 million
appropriated in the last budget so we
chased down admin Services um to find
out what work had been done done on this
um because we got presented several
numbers in the Senate one was the number
to construct the project and two was a
number to operate the project so as
Senator
rosenal um suggests about um whether
private companies can operate or not
operate the forensic hospital um no
decisions have been made on this um
actual construction isn't even going to
get to that point till sometime next
year that we can you know do this but
reality is we were presented numbers
that were a million dollars a person
which did not seem right the Senate
phase so um we basically said we believe
we can come back the same thing we're
all doing um with the sununu Senate to
be honest with you we don't believe
that's appropriate what's being spent so
we do believe that we need to build this
building because if you look at the
people that are land some of the people
that are landing in um New Hampshire
hospital they could be in this building
um and we could Fe free up drf beds
which throughout this whole session
right now we're carrying numbers in drf
beds that aren't acceptable for children
or for adults so there's all kinds of
solutions being worked on this is one
solution that if it were built on the
hospital grounds which is not the work
they originally started out with they
were going to do a freestanding unit um
they think they can achieve you know
some ability to bring down the costs if
we do it on that property um and they
asked us if we appropriate 30 million in
the Senate don't put so many strings on
us right now that we can't work to get
this project done so we gave him some
flexibility um we had the money from
2021 that we believe could be freed up
for this because you didn't have that
choice choice in the house and we do
believe it will help us with drf beds
and in the long run we believe we can
make it affordable I I don't know what
the solution is going to be on how to
run it to be honest with you Senator
Bradley yeah and and let me just add to
when we authorized in the last budget
the $ 8.7 million there my understanding
is there was a provisor in that budget
that said it would not be run as a
for-profit um prison that if I
understand it correctly law still
applies here so while that could change
I suppose um my understanding is that it
would not be subject to private
operation Rosen Wald is well I think I
could we ask the LBA because I think
what we had been told was that this
Senate's new language did make a change
to what the
operation of the spu could
be I guess I'll just turn to K and see
if he's heard anything from the
Department on
that operation as far as who could
operate it the department or a private
entity um there was talk about adding
some language to include the
restrictions that were included in the
trailer Bill two years ago um I don't
believe that language ever made it in
the language that was in the trailer
Bill two years ago is still in effect
however um it applies to that original
$8.75 million appropriation so I'm not
really sure how that would be
interpreted going forward given that
this new appropriation has been
made Senator Morris yeah I'll be honest
with you you're gonna be back here
debating it because the numbers that
were presented to the Senate um were 27
million for 25 beds 50 million for 60
beds
none of us in the Senate thought those
numbers made any sense and I think we
have to come back and figure out you
know let's get the construction going on
this um because drf beds are tough to
come by in the state of New Hampshire
and if we can pull them out of New
Hampshire hospital and and use this I
think it's part of the solution but I
believe the legislator is going to have
to figure out how to operate it um I'm
not willing to take anything off the
table and I'm not suggesting anything
was put on the table because it was
um what was in the last budget I didn't
participate in so I don't I don't know
yeah I I I think we I think we should
just acknowledge that we've made some
progress because from what was being
proposed in March as a standalone
building they've got a collocation
that's going to save us on Staffing
inevitably and so so already they've
looked at the operational cost long term
and figured out a way to to drive those
down a little bit I I don't think we're
done with the operational piece but when
we did met on this there was no there
were no operational estimates so so
we're I think we're getting smarter but
we are going to have to continue to to
work through it so the house is going to
exceed to these two sections and
obviously more work will be done both
sides are talking about that work so we
will move forward together that brings
us to 420 Mr King section 420 and
421 uh relate to an action taken in
house bill one uh for non laap s some 21
available funds for nursing services and
nursing facilities of about $1 million
which is budgeted in restricted account
in house bill one so sections 420 and
421 would allow that to occur the house
exceeds to those two sections 422 please
sections
422 U and 423 I believe it related to
home visiting programs for Medicaid
eligible pregnant women infant and
families with children up to the age of
one and Kevin do you have any more
background on that I don't no okay so we
don't have any additional background to
defer to the Senate the house will
exceed to the to the Senate section 424
please section
424 uh suspends The Graduate medical
education payments um under the Medicaid
Program uh upon approval of state plan
Amendment shall be suspended through the
B this is a similar section that's been
included in uh prior
budgets if I could um Mr Ripple as I as
I remember this this was one of another
one of those examples of something that
had been discontinued but had found
another life in our uh H2S and and we
just allowed it to die could you could
you correct my memory please uh I'm not
sure there was a vote taken on whether
to include this or not I believe it was
included in language that the department
presented to division 3 and asked
division 3 to consider U but I don't
think it was formally voted
on repres
wer was this something we saw in the 529
unique program that they were going to
take money out of that uh this is
unrelated this is uh graduate medical
education payments that go to hospitals
such as Dartmouth teaching hospitals um
a supplemental payment provided to those
hospitals that has not been um provided
uh if I go back probably since
2011 potential I I think I'm all in
favor anytime we suspend payments so I I
I'd be okay with this the house exceeds
to the
Senate section
425 section 425 appropriates
$300,000 for fiscal year 22 and 23 for
the Juvenile Diversion program and I
believe Kevin correct me if I'm wrong
it's also applies to section
426 that's right
yes so so Edwards do have a question
thank thank you madam chair the division
three uh did not discuss this so I don't
know what the program parameters are
around this and so a seeding to this
would be to rely on the Senate's
judgment that this is money well spent
and that there are metrics showing
success
so this is something that uh Senator G
pushed in in an amendment and something
quite frankly that we have funded uh
these diversionary programs to try to
keep kids out of hot water um
so they've been successful in the past
we hope that you go along with us I'm
I'm willing to trust the Senate the
house will
exceed we're on page 328 section
427 sections
427 on
328 section 428 that continues on 328
goes through 329 and section 429 are
relative to the Medicade uh Dental
benefit it appropriates about
$1.46 million to HHS for the purpose in
FIS year ending June 30th 23 for the
purpose of implementing the dental
benefit represent Madam chair
uh request that we hold
that okay we will hold
that um Mike I think that brings us to
section 430 yes page 330 yes section 430
on page 330 uh limits home visiting
programs to available uh
Appropriations representative Edwards
I'd be inclined to exceed are you in
agreement yes ma'am okay the house will
exceed section
431 section 431 suspends the U income
eligibility and the In-N-Out medical
assistance program uh which was passed
by chapter 39 of
20120 so this is a suspension we're
going to exceed yes
yes turning the page to page 331 we are
on
432 on page 33 1 Senate section
432 U this is relative to the Medicaid
to schools program you remember in house
bill one that there was a $15 million
year reduction to the Medicaid to
schools program based on current
expenditures of those federal funds the
department does have the ability to go
back to fiscal committee to accept and
expend those federal funds uh Senator
Hennessy did though want to require that
any request to the fiscal committee
shall include a detailed explanation of
the types of assistance the department
is providing to to school distance to
ensure eligibility for reimbursement
under the Medicaid the schools program
bless her heart the house will exceed to
that
433 section 433 it is an appropriation
of $1.5 million in fiscal 21 for the
purpose of providing grants to senior
centers serving senior citizens for
supporing services combat struggles with
Mental Health and Social isolation uh
this was a section included in House
Bill uh two as introd used it was
removed uh by the house due to revenues
and added back in the Senate um which
will be applied to 21 and
[Music]
nonlinguistic 's office as a way to
upgrade U barrier materials and senior
citizens centers and and because this is
about seniors and it's the same number
1.5 million I'm just curious is this the
same appropriation under a slightly
different purpose or are we doing
something different here this is you saw
this language in the house uh something
very similar to it was included in the
governor's recommended house bill to uh
the only difference here is in addition
to the roation being made out of fiscal
21 is originally there was a provision
allowing the money to be spent on
infrastructure improvements and that
language has been removed so no
infrastructure all right so so the bad
part of it that was like 80 90% of it
got removed and this this new purpose
has been injected I I think we should
hold this and discuss it because uh it's
shape shifting under us okay we will
hold 433 and
434 435 Mr Mr K sure 435 is an
appropriation in 21 of the Veterans Home
Master Plan update this would uh
initially was included in House Bill 25
it was removed um in the which is the
capital budget it was removed by the
public works committees and instead uh
the Senate included this as a 21
appropriation I don't think this should
have been bonded so the house will
exceed to this okay so that includes
sections 435 and 436 on the bottom of
page 331
correct 437 we're going to pay off the
mortgage yes on page 332 section 437 is
currently a $2.75 million appropriation
from the general fund to pay off the
lottery building uh mortgage which they
purchased last bium um it will reduce
debt service costs by about $200,000 a
year I believe we have an amendment for
Senator Morse okay Senator Morris I have
amendment
1917s that would basically Ally just
take the funding Lottery working with
their accountants um said the
appropriation to pay off the debt should
come out of Lottery which means we'll
probably lower
education um fund at the end of the year
I would think I don't know might can't
by 2.7 but we'll increase the general
fund rainy day fund by 2.7 that's
basically what this will do that's
correct you move your
Amendment sure if I can sure go ahead
Senator Bradley
moves represent wer seconds the adoption
of amendment
221-1
917s all those in favor on the house
side can I ask a question you may ask a
question thank
you um so this this money instead of
coming out of general fund comes out of
the lottery pot before Lottery transfers
money out before okay
Lottery's made a ton of money this year
um so I know and I'm hoping they make a
ton next year plus 2.7 but so it just
this just really is uh making sure that
Lottery keeps itself within
Lottery no Lottery's accountants believe
they have to do that but this was so
that we save
$400,000 the bud yeah all right no I did
I got it okay thank you okay so the
house is in favor raise your hand yes
the
Senate motion passes and with that we
have moved those two sections on I went
a hold on the Kino license fee okay
which is section
439 uh section 440 Mr Kane sure section
440 um you remembered earlier today
discussed how historic horse racing uh
was signed into law by the governor I
believe last week uh Senator GAA had an
amendment Rel he was approached by one
entity that uh would like to offer
historic horse races um and as a result
of that they did want to bump out the uh
date so someone who was operating as a
May 1st 21 just so they could be
captured by the new uh
game repres
Burger I'm not sure why we need a date
in there at all I mean because if some
other facility comes along in
2025 does that mean I have to have a
bill to allow them to do historic horse
racing Mr Kane do you want to answer
that before I call on representative
rosenal yeah so I probably defer to
Senator Rosen okay Senator Rosen I think
that in this language is um just kind of
a stop and limit the licenses just for
three
years while we establish a store course
racing okay we can look into that I
think you're you're you're right Cindy I
forgot yeah represent
wer I think we passed this historic
horse racing and now if we throw any
more stuff and as allow to be a conflict
in the language I would just as soon
take all this out of the
hb2 because we've passed a bill in both
House and Senate for historic horse
racing I don't want to confuse it any
further normally OS will make sure
there's no conflict between hb2 and
whatever might have passed in some other
legislation am I am I correct correct
that's correct section 441 the Senate
has asked to put this on hold that is
440 and
441 and uh 442 as well get Capt 42 thank
you
so that moves us to
443 and the house will exceed to the
Senate language I remove that money
reluctantly when we were in division one
but I needed to fund training and our
prisons which had been zeroed out so I'm
glad to see 443 and 444 back that brings
us
to um 445 does anybody we've looked at
this lot does anybody need discussion of
these
sections we're in agreement we seating
the house exceeds to section 445 and the
applicable assoc Associated sections
Mike you may know those numbers better
yes through
447 which I believe 447 goes all the way
to page
346 I believe yes
okay we just zip
through bunch of
pages and we would like to hold on
we no we did not we killed the
bill we killed the bill or not we're g
to hold and double
check I know you can't you're just
hurting us we did Kill the bill no I
don't believe you did I checked it this
morning we're gonna hold and double
check ourselves well that's fine but I
think there was a motion to table that
failed we will double
check
Aaron can you do that for
us
well Woodsville bill this is Rick Lads
Woodsville fire district bill can you
tell me tomorrow we're gonna hold it now
if we passed it or killed it or put it
on table or did
something thank you so we will just zip
right past it with it on hold yes and
that will include section 449 and 450 as
well and take you to section 451 through
460 which begin on page 348 at the
bottom and that is relative to
establishment of uh two things that
microenterprise fund as well as live
venue assistance using co uh using
Federal relief
funds where are we on
this Mr
speaker tomorrow
okay so we'll hold sections 451 through
460 that will bring you to page 353 with
Senate section
461 uh which is an appropriation to the
Department of Health and Human Services
for p child protector service worker
positions in total about $1.5 million
over the bayum for those
positions I believe this was a floor
am okay we don't see to know what we
want to do with this
one
okay Mike how many sections does this
take in effect um relative to the micro
Enterprise Relief Fund and save our
Granite
stages yeah that's 451 through 460
through
460 sorry that ends on page
353 yeah I my book turned the wrong way
up so I couldn't find the
section sorry about that this this
printing has been interesting all right
ladies and
gentlemen exceed what do we want to
do are are you on the child protective
workers uh microenterprise really fund
and save our Granite stages
still we're holding all you want to hold
all that okay we want to hold all that
okay that will bring you to page 353
section 461 now we've moved on chest to
yes and this is the appropriation of
about 1.5 million over the buy name for
Child Protective Services of which about
uh a little over a million dollars is
General
funds so so so division three did not um
cut these we we we supported the
governor's uh budget what we what we did
do though was we uh imposed a ceiling at
3,000 to give the commissioner
flexibility to to hire priority hires
and um I'm I'm not I'm not sure where
these additional this additional head
count is coming from since it I don't
believe it was sourced in the original
Governor's
budget so um going going back into the
2019 session when we passed Senate Bill
six we authorized all of these positions
as I recall right now there are 37
unfilled positions at DCF so what this
amendment does in section
461 it um funds 10 of them of the
authorized positions over and above the
unfilled and the remain in 12 because
there were 22 additional positions that
were authorized the remaining 12 could
come back to fiscal for approval so it
was approved in the past budget um and
it the whole design of it is to get the
case loads down to a manageable number
um per case worker but isn't the problem
right now they have as you noted
37 funded but unfilled positions so one
of the reasons the case loads don't go
down is they can't find people to hire
their positions rather than we're
shorting them staff isn't that where we
are but we are not shorting them staff
no that's uh that's absolutely true
these are difficult jobs to have um
there's High turnover the department has
made a great effort since I think a
number of us starting in
2017 um you know senator Carson I think
LED efforts
to um increase the number of positions
at DCF given some of the notable
failures that had happened of deaths
among children under DCF care um the
office of the child advocate was formed
at that point so over that period of
time many more positions have been um
created and according to Senate Bill 6
from 20
19 if all 22 of those positions and the
37 positions that were unfilled were
filled then we would have a full
compliment but again representative over
because of the difficulty of the job um
so that's been that has been the issue I
think the department has um you know
made great strides in trying to improve
dcyf but difficult jobs um certainly
exacerbated by Co too so the second
question I have before we leave that and
then representative Wilder's got a
question this and representative Edwards
touched on this these additional people
still must be are not in
addition to the 3,000 they've allocated
it's a cap of 3,000 employees but 10 of
these may be part of that 3,000 is that
where you are well under Senate Bill six
and I can't remember the overall number
of new positions that were um funded but
the my understanding is when the budget
was first submitted there were 22
positions that were not included because
of the
vacancies this amendment that the Senate
adopted would fund 10 of those 22 with
the ability to come back but but still
under the top Max of 3,000 employees for
a CH yeah um LBA would have to answer
that question I I do not know Mr okay
the house would like this to be clear
that it's still 3,000 is the top number
of employees that HHS may have okay so
we'll um we could draft an amendment to
refer to that section in house Bell one
just to make sure it's consistent with
the actions taken by the committee on
house B one would that be a new section
um we could probably add it um to these
Provisions since this is chapter law we
could probably just St a sub paragraph 3
uh clarifying
that so if representative Edwards if
we're going to do that we will have to
hold this representative wer still got a
question but representative wer thank
you madam chair since we earlier decided
to eliminate positions that had been
empty for three years that might apply
to many of these positions so there's
might be a conflict here when Senate
Bill six and 19 so my understanding is
that when we adopted this amendment we
overrode that provision okay um because
of the the need quite frankly to protect
children from abuse and neglect I'm just
wondering if we need to add language to
say that this is an
exception Mr Kane did we already do
that so you've adopted the section
relative to to abolish positions which
is a previous section um just not off
the top of my head uh there is a um if
you would like when we're drafting the
amendment here we can reference that
previous section relative to abolished
positions just to make sure that this
does not
apply please so we will hold this
pending the amendment we're
discussing which is going to bring us
to page
454 yes so the um 3544 correct section
462 yes section 462 is an appropriation
of
$600,000 and22 and $600,000 23 uh to HHS
for the purpose of funding Community
collaborations and parental Assistance
programs um at
HHS representative Edwards are we in
agreement with
this we don't actually know what this is
so we should hold this and get an
explanation of of what this community
Assistance looks like because because I
don't I don't think we talk about this
maybe Mr Ripple could help us right
now I can give you a brief explanation I
know the funds would be used for
contracts with four entities to
facilitate improved parent child
interactions and reduce child Mal
treatment and I know that one of the
contracts would be the department of
corrections as far as what specifically
the funds are used for I'm not sure okay
we're gonna hold
this uh Mr Kane I would like you to pass
out Amendment 2021 D1
197h please
okay
Jess let Karen sit it's not
you I have a
copy
okay to my friends in the Senate with 24
members we in the house have 400 members
we will be having our last house session
still in the Bedford Sports Arena now
that the executive orders have expired
we have no way to pay house members
their travel mileage to and from so we
would and you're out of money don't give
me
that so you hit it all represent wer is
is going to move the adoption of this
section and representive umberger who
makes a long drive is going to second
that any discussion on the Senate
side the
recess one of those
yeah house members in
favor senate members is in favor we
appreciate that thank you very much Mr
Kane could we pass out Amendment 202
one-1 1932 AG please
yes thats good
[Laughter]
foresight you know about this one you
didn't know about the last
one you're sounding like the Senate do
it two times
no
wheny I have it when the Adent General
came to division one he had cut the
money to the Civil Air Patrol
representative Edwards talked about that
when we talked about
hb1
um we do now have more money it would be
the House's position that we would like
to restore that funding to a level
fund hold on you can hold on this we
will hold on
this that is actually I think we're at
the end oh Karen do you have an
amendment you would like to present uh
yes I do this is amendment um 2021
1944 and it's dealing with um gun line
the gun
line I think the hard copies of that one
were left across the street so we don't
have to bring those back over sorry
about that delete Amendment no
no no it's not it should be but it
isn't okay so if you could yeah we can
wait till tomorrow on this it's no no
big deal I'd like to thank the house
chief of staff for looking this up for
me if we could turn back to page
346 the house that originally said hold
on Section
448 however we have passed it so now I
wonder if we need this or we should
delete it
um I would hope that the uh senate or
the house would go along with this um
it's very important to sen guy well I
understand but we passed the
bill we passed the bill which was Bill a
Senate
bill and
so not been signed in a law but it's
going you think the governor is going to
veto
it can we hold on this so that okay now
the sen would like to hold now the
Senate would like to hold on this
section
absolutely so that we can talk to Center
GA yes
yes
okay about lot
things the time being 37 we have gone
through our book both sides have said
that they would like to hold on things I
would propose the following to see if it
means meets with your H do you have an
amendment absolutely bring that
Amendment
up yes do you have that sure we just
need that body warn
[Music]
dashboard bu warn camera
sorry and you guys have any other
amendments you want
okay we talk on it the
same
yeah
thank
you okay we have in front of us
Amendment 202 one-1 1939 s from Senator
Bradley Senator Bradley yes thank you
very much Madam chair
um this amendment ensures that the
provisions of House Bill two with regard
to body warn dashboard camera fund take
precedence over Senate Bill
96 um this is fleshed out the
appropriation more as I recall Senate
Bill 96 only had a dollar
appropriated um and it had somewhat
different language but I think this is a
more comprehensive
approach represent bumberger
Senate Bill 96 did not come to you
because the house did not do second
committee bill so you didn't see it but
I did read it over the weekend because
Senator Bradley had called me it would
have come to you if we done second
committee
bills my understanding is that the
department of safety is currently
looking to get a
comprehensive contract to lease body
cameras which will make it cheaper
overall and this ensures that not only
these guys but Department of corre c s
in their use would be using the same
contract uh for leasing which will
reduce the cost
significantly I I guess because I did
not see SB 96 96 I know
um I
I telling you this this looks exactly
like the language we already have in
there but if
must not my understanding is the only
real um change to the Senate version of
hb2 with regard to this is that the
effective date
um ensures that this provision take
precedence over what's in Senate Bill
96 it has July 1 2021 at 1201
a.m. so one minute past midnight this
goes into
effect doesn't have an
appropriation the appropriation remains
in section 146 unchanged that's a
million
dollars no that's okay take your
time
you
if it helps representative bumberger I I
didn't notice any changes except the
addition of the RSA 612 reference and
145a if I'm not
mistaken the reason I say that is that
the effective
date you had the effective date here I
think of June 30th
2021 that's the Appropriations that's
the
Appropriations yeah yeah thank you madam
chair uh could someone once again just
explain what the purpose of this is and
exactly what it accomplishes thank you
so the purpose of this well let let's
back up a little bit it was a
recommendation of the leak commission
that the governor um implemented last
year that um to the extent possible um
police forces have dashboard or body
video um just
to keep a record if you will of anything
that might happen I think it's broadly
supported by law enforcement you know in
my conversations with the chiefs of
police they um are fully supportive of
this I think it's a way of protecting AC
ing police officers um so I get all that
I'm just the the actual change the
slight difference in the wording what
does that accomplish well as I said
before it's the effective date um to
make sure that this supersede Senate
Bill
um had a slight had different
language incate Bill 96 would take
effect on July 1 usually at midnight so
by putting in the July 1st 2021 at 12:01
a.m. uh that ensures that the house bill
two Provisions take over
that uh I I'm not having any problem
with this I just okay I just so do we
have a motion to adopt 2021 D
representative umberger moves to adopt
2021 D1 1939 s and represent kott
seconds house members if you're in favor
raise your
hands
Senate we have adopted it do we have any
more amendments this
evening Mickey you said that we had um
this other one has
come
over the
1944 is that the one relative to Senate
Bill 141 yes we don't have still across
the street Sor okay fine no
problem I ask that that Amendment be
distributed to us so that we can talk to
the sponsor of the
bill Karen that's your Amendment Yes or
No
Yes um actually you can have the only
copy that's here I'll run you
one Mr Shay I sent you a text at lunch
about one more Amendment we need I
assume that hasn't come
yet we've gotten
that we haven't gotten that
okay all right do we have any other
amendments and when that amendment is
ready can you also distribute it to the
senate
members as well as the house members
thank
you and that Amendment
adds the audit that Das commission would
like to have on where we are on a
certain funds
so okay then I think we're now ready to
propose where we're going to go I would
propose that this Committee of
conference reconvene at one o'clock
tomorrow in this room we have mornings
when both bodies probably need to work
on some language we've passed some
amendments out to you we didn't make any
attempt to work on we've got some
amendments that we just saw today so is
that agreeable to the
Senate yes then we are in recess until
one
o'clock Tuesday which is
tomorrow thank
you Mike are you gonna give us the uh
shaded out
version you think we can get it in the
morning BR it up to Janet
and
moment